[Music]
this morning on the dish chef zach
pollock his culinary journey began in
florence italy where he fell in love
with the country's food and culture
after honing his skills abroad he
returned to his los angeles roots
opening the critically acclaimed eatery
elemento and now he's followed that up
with kosabuana his inventive approach to
casual italian cuisine our jamie wax
paid pollock a visit to see how he turns
the simple into the extraordinary
fire mod sticks to go
and 33 single pepperoni to experience
chef zach pollock's beautiful flavorful
often whimsical take on italian cuisine
while sitting across the table from the
chef himself hmm
wow is to be in the presence of
something akin to a teenager discovering
the joy of his life that is not the
cheese stick from the mall did you go
ranch
combined with a disciplined artisan
studied in the skills details and
techniques of ancient cultures as when
he describes the cuisine in his pizza
focused restaurant when we opened 90 of
the menu was kind of written already by
what kinds of things a pizzeria has and
the exercise here has always been
executed as best as we possibly can use
all the techniques that we've learned
and you know bring it home and kind of
keep it an honest portrayal of what it
should be like his dishes it all comes
together perfectly when one considers
that he found his passion for cooking
while pursuing his passion for
architecture as a college student
studying abroad in italy i got
distracted while i was there the way
italians engage with food and wine was
unlike anything i'd ever experienced
food is not just something that is
consumed it's it's a ritual it's a part
of life it connects them to their
history it connects them to their
geographies and that was just something
that really blew my mind you say the
florentine central market really pulled
you in and all of the foods and
experiences there it was so overwhelming
it probably was like a kid in a candy
store and i was just totally bowled over
and had a little apartment there and i
would buy whatever i could and bring it
back to my apartment and on a little
tiny like two burner cook whatever i
could cook do you remember the moment
where you really shifted from saying i i
don't think i'm gonna be an architect
anymore i think this is gonna be my life
i remember being in that little
apartment and saying this is
something is going on here
and i need to
at least give it a try
after a brief return to convince his
parents of the shift in his career focus
the los angeles native started a series
of exhausting but meaningful
apprenticeships back in italy i remember
starting service
and then literally and this is not
hyperbole literally the woman that was
running the station where i was dodging
that night said okay it's time to break
down and i looked up at the clock and it
was like 11 45 and i was in total
disbelief and that's when i knew okay
like something about restaurant cooking
that is that you're going to find really
fulfilling and i've always found it
really fulfilling you you lost yourself
and lost time in that first experience
the first day and after years of
diligent work in the kitchens of
respected chefs the l.a boy brought all
his knowledge and creativity back home
to both honor traditional italian
cuisine and
to turn it on its head with the
elegantly appointed and sophisticated
elemento
and his inspired take on a classic pizza
joint cosa buona the spot where the
restaurant is
has been a pizzeria since i think the
50s
so carrying on that tradition was really
important it was at cosa buona that he
set up a spread for us that was nothing
short of an architectural masterpiece
just make sure you don't stab it with
the fork no i'm gonna lift it italian
soup dumplings a complete reversal of
tortellini and broto people have got to
smile when this comes to the table it's
like right it's just when this comes
it's fun
yeah crispy polenta with salmon roe um
yes
that's all i can say is yes to every bit
of this
the texture the flavors two chopped
salads one more traditional with salami
and pepperoncini the other with fried
chickpea polenta and an emulsified
vinaigrette
his irreverently reverent hawaiian pizza
just because there's a lot of you know
pizza out there with pineapple that
maybe isn't good doesn't mean that pizza
and pineapple can't be friends you like
that challenge absolutely and a unique
eggplant parm that cooks overnight
all of this is really very traditional
in its construction and in its flavor
profile totally and like there there
definitely is like you say a lot of
inspiration from maybe techniques from
other cultures it all at the end of the
day is hopefully paying homage to its
roots everything here makes cohesive
sense
it seems to be
a guy having a lot of fun with his
creativity and with with both his
limitations and the fact that there are
no limits really it's funny you say that
because i actually think that i work
much better when there are limits when
there are boundaries those boundaries
would force creativity i think that's
why i
kind of went from architecture into
cooking because they are both very
creative fields but they are also
heavily bound by
by rules right now at the end of the day
the house has to stand up if it if it
looks gorgeous but it falls down you
haven't done your job as a chef it can't
just look great certainly and it can't
even just taste great or then we'd all
just make candy bars it has to it has to
be nutritious it has to nourish and
after a career spent bringing new ideas
to the table
zach [ __ ] is grateful that he can
once again bring diners to the table
i've always loved you know entertaining
and and and making people happy and you
know there is an ambitious program that
comes with that which is how do we bring
more of these to other parts of los
angeles we're looking at possible other
locations well you need to put the new
location near my house please that's all
i have very good because you've made
this person very happy today i can tell
you
for cbs saturday morning shalou
cheers
jamie wax los angeles
we are so mad at you right now jamie
because that looks so good how hungry oh
my god right now i take one of
everything yeah and beautiful not just
the flavor i'm sure was wonderful but
the presentation everything looked so
good i also like the hawaiian pizza with
the jalapeno my wife is a huge hawaiian
pizza fan i'm not but i would that it's
a debate i might try that yeah yeah
marco loves that too yeah it's a winner
what can we say